This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Look at that. It's like a Three houses all in a row or like a set of stairs. I love those moments when you're walking in your neighborhood and suddenly Nothing is familiar. It's like a staircase for a giant. I don't want to meet It's like a staircase for a giant. I don't want to meet that giant. Not that you don't know where you are, but where you are, where you've always been, seems foreign somehow.
这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。你看那个。就像三栋房子连成一排，或者像一组楼梯。我喜欢这样的时刻：你在街区里散步，突然一切都变得陌生起来。这就像是给巨人准备的楼梯。我可不想去见——这就像是给巨人准备的楼梯。我可不想去见那个巨人。倒不是说你不知道自己在哪里，而是你所在的地方、你一直身处的地方，不知为何显得有些陌生。
In a good way. I've never noticed this gym before. It's a beautiful little street, an old boxing house. It happened to Sean Cole, friend of the show, back in the spring. He lives in Brooklyn up in the northern part near Queens. You know, a Gallagher, the comedian talks about when you have a kid and you start seeing the world with new eyes, I was kind of seeing my neighborhood with new eyes. It's up to you, no, I have a kid. In my case, it was due to this artist that I was going to meet, that's why I was walking
这是件好事。我以前从来没注意到过这个健身房。这是一条漂亮的小街道，一个古老的拳击馆。这事发生在肖恩·科尔身上，他是节目的朋友，就在今年春天。他住在布鲁克林北部靠近皇后区的地方。你知道的，加利哈格，那个喜剧演员谈到当你有了孩子，你开始用新的眼光看待世界时，我差不多也是用新的眼光看待我的街区。随你便，不，我有个孩子。就我而言，这是因为我要去见这位艺术家，所以我才走在
through the neighborhood. And what's his name? His name is James Gulliver Hancock. Here we are. He told me to meet him at this cafe, not far from where I live, called Cookie Road, right on time. And he goes, the old Cookie Road, though, not the new one on Manhattan Avenue.
这个街区里。他叫什么名字？他叫詹姆斯·格利弗·汉考克。我们到这儿了。他让我在这个咖啡馆见他，离我住的地方不远，叫“曲奇之路”，准时到达。他说，不过是老“曲奇之路”，不是曼哈顿大道上的那条新“曲奇之路”。
And I'm thinking, what do you know about the new one? You live in Australia. James, microphone in hand. Microphone in hand. How are you? Good. new one, you live in Australia. James, microphone in hand. How are you? Good. Good to meet you. But the thing about James Gulliver Hancock is that he just
我在想，你对新路了解多少？你住在澳大利亚。詹姆斯，手里拿着麦克风。手里拿着麦克风。你好吗？很好。新路，你住在澳大利亚。詹姆斯，手里拿着麦克风。你好吗？很好。很高兴见到你。但詹姆斯·格利弗·汉考克的特点在于他
knows this city so intimately. He did use to live here from about 2010 to 2012. And back when he lived here, and this is why I was going to meet him, back when he lived here, he started this pretty obsessive little project that ultimately culminated in a book. Yeah, so I have the book. Oh, great.
对这座城市如此熟悉。他确实从 2010 年到 2012 年左右在这里住过。当他住在这里的时候——这也是我要去见他的原因——当他住在这里时，他开始了这样一个近乎痴迷的小项目，最终结集出了一本书。对，所以我带了这本书。哦，太好了。
And the name of the book, I have to say I love the title. It's so earnest. Is all the buildings in New York. All the buildings in New York that I've drawn so far. Yeah. It's like what a six-year-old would close. Like it? What I like about it is that it was that in time.
至于这本书的名字，我必须说我很喜欢这个书名。它是如此真诚。《纽约所有的建筑》。《到目前为止我画过的所有纽约建筑》。对。就像一个六岁小孩会起的名字。喜欢吗？我喜欢它的一点是，它表明了当时的状态。
That's how it implies that you're going to draw more. Sure. Well, there are buildings. I like the first part of the title of the mix. So he's saying he wants to draw all the buildings in New York? I think he would like to. How many buildings are there in New York? 100,000 buildings.
这暗示着你以后还要画更多。当然。嗯，这里有建筑。我喜欢书名前半部分的意思。所以他是说他想画完纽约所有的建筑？我想他是挺想的。纽约有多少栋建筑？十万栋建筑。
Are there 900,000 buildings? I think so. I would maybe just sell my hat. It would, you would probably need to spend a lot more time here. Sure. I actually looked this up later. In the New York City Property Tax Annual Report of 2011, it said there were 1,030,202 parcels, but I think parcels also
有九十万栋建筑吗？我想是的。我可能得把我的帽子卖了。那可能，你得在这里花更多的时间。真的。我后来真的查了查。根据 2011 年纽约市财产税年度报告，上面说有 1,030,202 个地块，但我想地块也
include separate condominium and rental units. And then I found myself on the website of something called M.Poris, which bills itself as a global provider of building information. And the number it said was closer to 728,452. The closer to that28,452. They're closer to that. Close roughly. In the book, there are only about 170. Most of them in Manhattan.
包括独立的公寓和出租单元。然后我发现自己在一个叫 M.Poris 的网站上，它自称是全球建筑信息提供商。上面给出的数字更接近 728,452。更接近于 728,452。它们更接近那个数字。差不多。书里只有大约 170 个。大部分在曼哈顿。
But you'd also draw around here in Brooklyn, and everyone here with the queens, and the Bronx, and the burrows, and the places. Yeah. Try to mix it up a bit. Yeah. He's hit every burrow except Staten Island, though he did draw the ferry.
但你也会在布鲁克林这边画，还有这里的每个人，皇后区、布朗克斯、各个行政区，还有那些地方。对。尽量把各种风格混搭一下。对。除了史泰登岛，他去过所有其他行政区，虽然他也画过渡轮。
And despite the title, these are not all the buildings in Island, though he did draw the ferry. And despite the title, these are not all the buildings in New York that he's drawn so far. The book is just a sampling of his blog of the same name. Actually, the blog is just called All the Buildings in New York. Without the, that I'm drawn so far. Without the, that I'm drawn so far, yeah. Because it's ongoing, you know.
尽管书名如此，这些并不是岛上所有的建筑，但他确实画过渡轮。尽管书名如此，这些并不是纽约所有的建筑，是他到目前为止画的。这本书只是他的同名博客的一个精选。实际上，博客的名字就叫《纽约所有的建筑》。没有“到目前为止我画的”这几个字。没有“到目前为止我画的”，对。因为这是一个进行中的项目，你知道的。
There's just about 500 drawings on it, something like that. Some of them are just black and white wiggly sketches. Others are these really loving, colored treatments with all kinds of intricate details. Just one per page, mostly. The way a little kid draws superheroes. The Empire State, the Krasla, all the classics. But also all these anonymous, down at the heels ones.
上面大约有 500 幅画，差不多吧。有些只是黑白的扭曲草图。其他的则是这种充满爱意的彩色处理，带有各种错综复杂的细节。基本上每页只有一个。就像小孩子画超级英雄那样。帝国大厦、克莱斯勒大厦，所有的经典建筑。但也有所有这些默默无闻、破败不堪的建筑。
The apartment houses. Cinego. Regarously labeled with the address, 53 Pitt Street, 222 West 23rd Street. Sky scribe at Brownstone, massive black monolith. But even the intricate drawings are still kind of cartoony, little squiggles and dots hovering above the roofs, as though the buildings are saying, look out!
公寓楼。……。都严谨地标上了地址，匹特街 53 号，西 23 街 222 号。褐石建筑上的摩天大楼，巨大的黑色巨石。但即使是那些复杂的画作也仍然有点像卡通，小小的波浪线和圆点悬浮在屋顶上方，仿佛这些建筑在说：小心！
Door, maybe, ta-da! I mean, why exactly? Oh right, yes, okay. So, um, well I've done this project in different fashions in different cities, so I've done all the rain in London and all the cars in Los Angeles and all the bicycles in Berlin, but he was just passing through those cities so he didn't dig in like with the buildings. And it's like he would parachute into a place and immediately try to find its noun. So the thing that the city was about in some way?
可能是门，哒哒！我是说，到底为什么？哦对了，是的，好吧。所以，嗯，我在不同的城市用不同的方式做过这个项目，我在伦敦画过所有的雨，在洛杉矶画过所有的汽车，在柏林画过所有的自行车，但他只是路过那些城市，所以他没有像对建筑那样深入挖掘。这就好像他空降到一个地方，然后立刻试图找出它的名词？
Yeah. I mean, Berlin might not be about bikes for everyone, but when I was there, everyone had a bike and there were bikes all over the place, just focusing on one thing and getting to know that one thing about that place, so trying to record it as obsessively as possible. But yeah, New York was definitely the buildings. And that's what I'm going to draw when I'm here.
也就是说，这座城市在某种程度上代表着什么？对。我的意思是，柏林可能并不意味着每个人都有自行车，但当我在那儿的时候，每个人都有一辆自行车，到处都是自行车，只需专注于一件事，去了解那个地方的那件事，然后尽可能痴迷地把它记录下来。但是，是的，纽约绝对就是建筑。这就是我在这里时要画的东西。
So I just started doing it and on it went. James and his wife moved home when she got pregnant so they could raise their kid in a place with more than one blade of grass sprouting from the ground. I can't even enjoy a blade of grass unless I know there's a way handy. The book and the blog have gotten a fair amount of buzz, a couple of big newspaper write-ups,
所以我开始画了，然后就一直画下去。詹姆斯和他的妻子在他妻子怀孕时搬回了家，这样他们就可以在一个除了从地面冒出一片草叶之外还有更多绿意的地方抚养孩子。我甚至无法享受一小片草坪，除非我知道附近有洗手间。这本书和博客引起了相当多的关注，几家大报做了报道，
and a lot of mentions on the blog is fear, including one that, due to a glorious typo, said James is on a mission to draw on the buildings in New York. A lot of the coverage really frames James as a kind of Don Quixote with a pen. This is from a segment on Good Day Sacramento and they talk to James via Skype. Now, this is New York. It's a tough city. There's some people yell at you like, why are you beating my building? What's going on?
博客上也经常被提及，其中包括一篇由于光荣的拼写错误而说詹姆斯肩负着“在纽约建筑上画画”的使命的文章。许多报道确实把詹姆斯塑造成了一个拿着钢笔的堂吉诃德。这是萨克拉门托美好的一天节目中的一个片段，他们通过 Skype 与詹姆斯交谈。听着，这是纽约。这是一座艰难的城市。有些人会冲你大喊，比如，你为什么要在我的建筑上画画？怎么回事？
No, it's more that it isn't New York, so people let you do it if you want, really. You know, it's a guy drawing on the street is probably one of the most normal things, you see. Go back the way we came, do you know what I'm saying? There's plenty more weird things than that around. Because there's a building just on the corner that I've drawn a couple of times. Go back the way we came. All right. There's plenty more weird things than that around. Because there's a building just on the corner that I've drawn a couple of times.
不，更准确地说，这里不是纽约，所以如果你想画，人们会让你画的。你知道，一个在街上画画的人可能是你见到的最正常的事情之一。按我们来的路回去，你知道我在说什么吗？周围还有更多奇怪的事情呢。因为街角刚好有一栋我画过好几次的建筑。按我们来的路回去。好的。周围还有更多奇怪的事情呢。因为街角刚好有一栋我画过好几次的建筑。
And what I wanted to do with James was go to some of the buildings he drawn and hold up the drawing next to the building, maybe to try to see what he sees. I'm only realizing this now, but you don't ever get to do that to sit with the artist in front of the thing that they made into a picture. Okay. There are a lot of Brooklyn buildings in the book, but I had my smartphone with me, so I figured we'd just call up his blog. The first drawing on his blog is in Greenpoint, actually.
我想对詹姆斯做的是，去一些他画过的建筑前，把画举在建筑旁边，也许是为了看看他看到了什么。我直到现在才意识到，你从来没有机会这样做——和艺术家一起坐在他们创作的图片前。好吧。书里有很多布鲁克林的建筑，但我带了智能手机，所以我想我们可以直接打开他的博客。他博客上的第一幅画实际上在绿点区。
The little apartment complex at 587 Manhattan Avenue. It's one of the loose, shambly charcoal sketches. Looks more like an idea for a building. James uploaded that picture on May 20th, 2010. He was still brand new to the city at that point, and this was sort of his way of keeping a diary of his time here. It also had the very real pragmatic function
曼哈顿大道 587 号的小型公寓综合体。这是那些随意、凌乱的木炭草图之一。看起来更像是一个建筑的概念。詹姆斯于 2010 年 5 月 20 日上传了那张照片。那时他对这座城市还是个完全的新人，这算是他记录自己在这里时光的一种日记方式。它还有一个非常现实的实用功能
of helping him get around town. That was one idea for the project to map this place that I didn't know very well for myself through drawing lots of different places. I mean, was it an effort to sort of contain... I mean, I lived here, I've only lived here two years, but I'm like, eh, I can't. Yeah, it's like where do you stop?
就是帮他在城里辨别方向。那是这个项目的一个想法，通过绘制许多不同的地方，为自己绘制这个我不太熟悉的地方。我的意思是，这是一种试图容纳……我的意思是，我住在这里，我只在这里住了两年，但我觉得，呃，我做不到。对，就像你从哪里停下来？
Yeah, you can't take it all in. Yeah. So was it where you're trying to bring the city down to 8 do you start? Yeah. You can't take it all in. Yeah. So was it where you're trying to bring the city down to 8 by 11 size? Yeah. Totally. You get a much deeper understanding of the place. You don't just sit in front of the cries of building and the Empire State, which I've done, but you sit in front of Joe Blogs's house on 5th Street or if it is in Ireland.
对，你无法全部吸收。对。所以，你是想把城市缩小到 8 乘以 11 的尺寸吗？对。完全是这样。你会对这个地方有更深刻的理解。你不只是坐在克莱斯勒大厦和帝国大厦前（虽然我也画过），而是坐在 5 街乔·布洛赫的房子前，或者如果它在爱尔兰的话。
And in a way, those buildings then become as kind of special as the Chrysler. Yeah, exactly, yeah. As iconic, I think, I've drawn that before, that grocery store with the three stories above it, and I think just that, that's just classic. He's pointing to 97 Franklin Street. We walk past it to Greenpoint Ave, plop down on a bench, James takes my phone and scrolls back on the blog to another bodega across the street from where we're sitting.
从某种意义上说，那些建筑随后变得和克莱斯勒大厦一样特别。对，没错，对。同样具有标志性，我想，我以前画过那个，上面有三层楼的杂货店，我想就是那个，那就是经典。他指着富兰克林街 97 号。我们走过它来到绿点大道，在一张长椅上坐下，詹姆斯拿过我的手机，在博客上向后滚动，翻到了我们坐的地方街对面另一家杂货铺。
Well, there's this one just there, the deli down the bottom. It's a similar one to the one we were talking about before. Oh, oh, look at that. So that one's a bit different, it's a bit messy. You've really captured it. I mean, I have to say it's like, well, it's a quirky version of it've really captured it. I mean, I have to say it's like... Well, it's a quirky version of it, you know?
嗯，就在那里，底下的那个熟食店。这和我们刚才谈论的那个很像。哦，哦，看那个。所以那个有点不同，有点乱。你真的抓住了它的精髓。我的意思是，我不得不说，这就像……嗯，这是它的一个古怪版本，你知道吗？
It's like, that's what I like about drawing. Like, it's not exactly, like I might have missed a few things and like, this isn't actually that. That's a bit further over, the bit down the middle. So it's all sort of a bit, uh... The windows down the middle again. Wabby Sabby, you know? It's a bit, uh, organic.
就像，这就是我喜欢画画的地方。就像，它不完全是，我可能漏掉了一些东西，比如，这实际上不是那样。那是再过去一点的中间部分。所以这一切都有点，呃……中间的窗户又来了。侘寂，你知道吗？这有点，呃，有机感。
And it's almost like you've made it more than what it is. Yeah, you bring out its character a bit. Yeah. Yeah. I can pull up this one too. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. This is 144 Franklin Street, an older, three-level apartment building that's lavished with all kinds of intricate design
而且感觉你把它画得比它本身更丰富了。对，你稍微展现出了它的性格。对。对。我也可以调出这一张。哦，对，对，对。这是富兰克林街 144 号，一栋较旧的三层公寓楼，装饰着各种错综复杂的图案
frills. It's one of those places that makes you think two things. One, who decided that this building, out of all of the buildings on this block, should be so crazily ornate. And two, you know, they just don't build places like that anymore. Do you know architectural terms? What do you call like that sort of filigree,
花边。这是那种会让你产生两种想法的地方。第一，谁决定在这条街的所有建筑中，这座建筑应该如此疯狂地华丽。第二，你知道的，他们再也造不出这样的地方了。你知道建筑术语吗？你管那种类似金丝细工的叫什么，
you know, the flowers that repeat going across the freeze-up top? I'm talking straight out of my bottom here. I mean, I know the top part is like a cornice, right? Cornice. But that's the funny thing, because I'm doing this largely architectural project, I constantly get asked about architecture, and I haven't trained in architecture,
你知道的，横跨顶部饰带不断重复的花朵？我这纯粹是在胡说八道。我的意思是，我知道顶部就像是檐口，对吧？檐口。但有趣的是，因为我主要在做一个建筑项目，所以我经常被问到关于建筑的问题，而我并没有受过建筑专业训练，
and I don't know the terms outside of the standard terms that everyone has. So yeah, it's hard to say what those things are. I just appreciate them and draw them and show them to others. I mean, I'd never have noticed them if he hadn't drawn them or if I wasn't sitting there with him. Sitting with James, it's like the whole city is a museum. Usually, you know, buildings are too big or too cookie cutter to notice, but because he's
除了每个人都知道的标准术语之外，我根本不知道那些专业术语。所以，是的，很难说那些东西是什么。我只是欣赏它们、画下来并展示给别人看。我的意思是，如果不是他画了它们，或者如果我没有和他坐在一起，我永远不会注意到它们。和詹姆斯坐在一起，感觉整座城市就像一座博物馆。通常你知道的，建筑太大或者太千篇一律而引不起注意，但因为他
drawing every window, every fire escape railing, he's eventually going to hit the funny little decisions or awkwardnesses that make that building that building, that nobody would notice otherwise. James used to have a studio in the old pencil factory just half a block down. The pencil factory's funny actually. The top of it all the way around is appointed with these pencils. They're vertical. It's like an incomplete crown going around the top story. Yeah. Just in case you forgot what they were making in there.
画了每一扇窗户、每一个防火梯栏杆，他最终会捕捉到那些让那栋建筑成为那栋建筑的有趣的小决定或笨拙之处，而这些是别人根本不会注意到的。詹姆斯过去在半个街区外的老铅笔厂有一个工作室。铅笔厂其实挺逗的。它的顶部四周都装饰着这些铅笔。它们是垂直的。就像一顶不完整的皇冠环绕着顶层。对。以防你忘了他们在里面制造什么。
I mean, it's like a 15, these are 15 foot long pencils. You're like pencils for a giant. That's the second time you mentioned giants. Thank you for keeping track. I've drawn a few on the roof of the building who can get up there. Can we? Oh, I'd love to.
我的意思是，就像 15 英尺，这些是 15 英尺长的铅笔。你会觉得这是为巨人准备的铅笔。这是你第二次提到巨人了。谢谢你一直记着。我在建筑屋顶上画过几个能上去的人。我们能上去吗？哦，我很乐意。
I hope it's open. Well, let's try. Yeah. We duck around the corner into this warehousey looking lobby and go right up to the top floor. I love these old elevators. We jog around to the stairwell, and James stops at a window for a second to point something out to me.
希望它是开着的。好吧，我们试试。好的。我们拐过弯，走进这个看起来像仓库的大堂，直奔顶楼。我喜欢这些老式电梯。我们小跑着来到楼梯间，詹姆斯在一个窗户前停了一秒钟，向我指出了一些东西。
The weirdest thing, just under the roofs on the buildings across the street are stenciled the address numbers of those buildings. See the numbers up at all? Just there, above where it says bar. Oh, yeah. Oh, how about that? It's really cute. You would never know.
最奇怪的是，街对面建筑屋顶的下方用模板喷涂了这些建筑的地址编号。看到顶部的号码了吗？就在那里，写着“酒吧”的字样上方。哦，是的。哦，真是这样。真可爱。你永远不会知道。
It's like, who is that for a giant? Yeah, just walking down the street. What is up with you with giants? Anyway, so. Oh, man. Oh wow. It's pretty cool up here. It's amazing up here.
这就像是，那是为哪个巨人准备的？对，走在街上。你跟巨人较什么劲？不管怎样，所以。天哪。哦，哇。上面挺酷的。上面太棒了。
360 degree view of Manhattan and Brooklyn and Queens. This is like a hell of a pad. It's a huge roof. And one of the iconic water towers on top that I live. So yeah, the Empire State, the Chrysler. All the classics over there. You know, it's crazy like now that I'm looking at the skyline from up here. I mean, it feels like because I spent so much time looking at your drawings, it feels like I'm
曼哈顿、布鲁克林和皇后区的 360 度全景。这简直是个绝佳的住所。这是一个巨大的屋顶。上面还有我喜欢标志性水塔之一。所以，是的，帝国大厦，克莱斯勒大厦。那边所有的经典建筑。你知道，太疯狂了，现在我从上面看着天际线。我的意思是，感觉就像因为我花了很多时间看你的画，所以感觉我看到的是
drawing as opposed to reality. The vibrations, the wiggly lines. I see someone's perspective, that's what I see. I see someone else's perspective. Right, I've tainted your eyes. Damn you. You're gonna see everything is quaint. I never thought I'd see this city as quaint. Everything's pastel. Exactly.
绘画而不是现实。那些震颤，那些扭曲的线条。我看到了某人的视角，这就是我所看到的。我看到了其他人的视角。没错，我污染了你的眼睛。该死的你。你会觉得一切都很古雅。我从没想过我会觉得这座城市如此古雅。一切都是粉彩色的。完全正确。
Well that's the thing about reading someone's diary, which kind of what this is, I guess. You have a different view in the world afterwards. Get inside someone's head. See their personal perspective. It just doesn't happen to be in words this time. It's in pictures. You know, I picked up the book again the other day
这就是阅读某人日记的感觉，这差不多就是这本书的本质，我想。之后你对世界会有不同的看法。走入某人的内心。看到他们的个人视角。只不过这次不是用文字表达。而是用图片。你知道的，前几天我又拿起了这本书
and just leafing through it for a minute and then walking outside to the street and looking up at the buildings I look up at all the time and kind of hate. Now, I don't know how else to say this. It's like they seemed fun all of a sudden and kind of carefully, it's like now they were these carefully made objects.
随意翻了几分钟，然后走到街上，抬头看着我一直以来都在看、甚至有点讨厌的建筑。现在，我不知道该怎么表达了。感觉它们突然变得有趣起来，而且小心翼翼地，就像它们现在是这些精心制作的物体。
I mean, you know that when you see the care that someone put into something and the genius of everyday decisions, I think it makes you almost pathologically optimistic. Somebody put care into this. The world is better because of it. And I think that that kind of optimism feeds James. I mean, it's funny that you say that because like I've been wondering, like, why is he such
我的意思是，你知道的，当你看到某人倾注的心血以及日常决策中的天才之处时，我想这会让你变得几乎是病态般的乐观。有人对此倾注了心血。世界因此而变得更美好。我认为这种乐观情绪滋养了詹姆斯。我的意思是，真搞笑，你这么说，因为我一直在想，为什么他是一个
a happy person? But I think that's why. Yeah. The way we'll say that he had a pessimistic little moment there on the roof. Because of course, he's not just looking at the city. He's looking at the impossible job he's carved out for himself. Makes me anxious that I can't do it all.
如此快乐的人？但我想这就是原因。好吧，我们可以说他在屋顶上有过一段悲观的小时光。因为当然，他不仅仅是在看着这座城市。他看着的是他为自己开辟的这项不可能完成的工作。这让我感到焦虑，因为我无法完成所有这一切。
You look here at this amazing view, and there's like that one, look at that, the seaplane's taking off. That's amazing. But that look at that, the seaplane's taking on. That's amazing. But that one over there, the sort of Rosemary's baby, Ghostbusters, Stull, on the brown with the creamy brickwork up the top decorative, the green copper roofing. I don't know what that is, I've never been there,
你看看这里这壮丽的景色，还有那个，看那个，水上飞机正在起飞。太棒了。但是那个，看那个，有点像《罗斯玛丽的婴儿》、《捉鬼敢死队》里的风格，棕色的，顶部有奶油色砖砌装饰，绿色的铜屋顶。我不知道那是什么，我从未去过那里，
but it makes me anxious that I might not get there. I want to do it, I want to draw that one. It makes you anxious why, exactly. Because I want to spend time drawing all of the different buildings. Especially when I'm crossing a bridge, you see the lyre of the land and you remember the name of the project and you want to do it, you know, the nine-year-old in me wants to just, let's do this! But what would it mean if you don't get to all of them or don't get to the ones that you want to do? I don't know, die an unhappy death. I don't know, do I force my son to start drawing them?
但这让我感到焦虑，因为我可能去不了那里。我想做这件事，我想画那个。这让你感到焦虑，到底为什么？因为我想花时间画所有不同的建筑。特别是当你过桥时，你看到了这片土地的全貌，你记起了这个项目的名字，你想去完成它，你知道的，我内心的那个九岁小孩只想说，我们干吧！但如果你画不完所有建筑，或者画不了你想画的建筑，那意味着什么？我不知道，带着遗憾死去吧。我不知道，我是不是该强迫我儿子开始画它们？
There you go. You carry on the legacy. Yeah, it'll be a legacy. It'll be generations and generations of handcuffs. He's probably gonna be an accountant. Why do you say that? He's won. I don't know. Or are you already doing maths? His mum's a performer and his dad's a drawer. Oh, I see. So he's gonna rebel. Yeah. Well, he may be a politician. Maybe. He can do it every once. That's a good deed.
给你。你来传承衣钵。对，这将是一代代汉考克的传承。他可能会成为一名会计师。你为什么这么说？他赢了。我不知道。还是你已经在学数学了？他妈妈是个表演者，他爸爸是个画家。哦，我明白了。所以他要叛逆。对。嗯，他可能会成为一个政客。也许吧。他可以偶尔做一次。那是一件好事。
Sure. I love banging bad, it's great. To you. Yeah. I've thought about it, I've only thought about it. Yeah, I don't think too hard. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole, our own Sean Cole, Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. And we have a new intern, her name is Avery Trouffleman.
当然。我喜欢大声喧哗，这太棒了。对你来说。对。我想过，我只是想过。好吧，我不会想得太深。本周的《99% 隐形》由肖恩·科尔、我们自己的肖恩·科尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马斯制作。我们还有一位新实习生，她的名叫艾弗里·特劳夫曼。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but right now you go to 999pi.org and you can look at amazing pictures of all the buildings in New York. I've drawn so far. Why are you painting my building? What's going on?
我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上的账号是 Roman Mars，但现在你可以访问 999pi.org，欣赏《纽约所有的建筑》中那些令人惊叹的图片。我到目前为止画的。你为什么要在我的建筑上画画？怎么回事？
That's 99%invisible.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是 99percentinvisible.org。来自 PRX 的广播电台。来自 PRX 的广播电台。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。